Hey, what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for a another
special edition of the Monday morning
podcast. If you knew my podcast, you'd
probably say, Hey, what's this special?
What's a special one?
Usually I'm here by myself laying in
my fucking underwear running my yet,
but every once in a while I
have a special guest and a this,
this person will not let you down.
This is one of my great friends in this
business is one of the funniest bastards
I have ever met in my life. He has a
new special coming out on Netflix, um,
called mouthful of shame on a,
that's already funny on March 14th
please welcome the legendary Jim Norton.
Thank you bill. That's a nice intro.
I don't know how to handle nice
things being said about me. I know.
Does it make you uncomfortable people?
I was going as big as I could go
because I was feeling you squirmy.
What am I great friends, one of the
best comics I ever saw just to listen.
Just watching you squirm over there.
I can handle personal things are a far
away. We are from one another. It is odd.
My manager's kind of sitting there
uncomfortable with this fucking giant cock
bulge in the middle. He looks
like a retired figure skater.
Sorry. All right. Anyways,
I can handle personal like,
cause we are great friends, but any
type of compliments of work I can't,
ain't makes me so like you like
watching clips of yourself,
I'm going to torture you for this next
hour. Drives me nuts, dude. I watched it.
We get to watch a clip of yourself when
they bring you back and then the people
in the room like, oh yeah, that
was good. It's so fucking worse.
If you ever do a talk show
and then they'll like,
and they play either something you've
already done or whatever you're promoting.
I literally will, uh, you know,
if they cut to it and I actually look to
monitor to see if the crowd's watching
it at home. And then I just literally,
I'll put my fingers in my ears if I have
to. I'll start humming. No humiliating.
Oh, it's horrific. Do it man.
I can't watch because then they
feel like they're fake laughing.
Like they don't really like it. They're
just playing along to be polite.
I feel like they're just kind of
being nice to little Jimmy Norton.
They just being polite to me. The
only way I can watch myself is if I'm,
I filmed myself at a club and I'm just
watching it. But the second that I would,
I knew it was going to be uploaded or
broadcasted and I know that everybody's
going to see it immediately.
I'm like, oh my God,
what did I do that with my hand?
What did this fucking sign?
Everything just so immediately. It's
horrific. But having said that, I uh,
I actually made sure my last
special that I sat through it.
I sat through a couple of times to make
sure that at least I had like the look
of it, the look of it right now.
Did you do that with your new special
mouthful of shame that comes out on March
4th I'm going to hype the shit
out of this. It's funny. Yeah,
I did it obsessive. I've probably seen
it about 60 times, but just in editing,
like I don't mind watching it to edit.
Like I go point by point
over both shows I want,
I know exactly what I
want from the late show.
I'll pull this from the early shot.
I'm really anal about it. That's good.
That's good to have. Yeah cause I
don't trust that like anyone else,
Netflix is easier cause
there's no commercials you
have to worry about and they
don't give a shit if it's 56 minutes for
promos it can be an hour and two hour
and three. So I was very comfortable
doing that. But like you said,
as soon as somebody else in the room,
I want to hang myself but
I can do it alone all day.
Cause I know I'm doing it as part
of, it's still part of the work.
But once it's done I'm like
I can never watch it again.
Oh I walk out of the room second.
Other people didn't watch it.
Oh Hey can I see a thing
here? And absolutely.
And then they sit down and I
closed the door and walk out.
Could you watch it with via? Could you
watch it with someone you're really,
really close to if like, it's not
like somebody you need to impress.
I just don't have to
standing up.
I would be standing up with my fucking
hands on top of my head like that. Like
good, is it good? Is it good? Is it soc?
I'd be doing that the whole time
and she literally gets mad going.
She knows at this point Nia
knows to be like, you know,
she'll just come up and say, Hey, I
watched your special, it was good.
Or I watched this, it was good and
blah blah blah. And I go, okay, good.
Well you start like if some of the parts
coming up that you don't like legally I
hated the way I did this thing like
right before it happens cause you like,
you don't want them to watch it and
pretend to like it when you know it's not,
it's fucking psychotic. Have that
thought buttons. It comes out like this.
I just, I just go
[inaudible] just a noise.
I just yell over
over and it just, it will bother her.
But I've also learned that, uh, yeah,
did just that. You're going to think
it's way, way worse than it fucking
goodness,
but don't you find the comedian to are
so comfortable watching themselves saw
something wrong with
that? Yeah man, I can't,
I keep your eye in back could literally
watch a fucking marathon of their entire
career and be like, Oh yeah, I love that
sport coat. I loved when I wore that.
The way I rolled those sleeves up.
I absolutely loved this one was a dog
and cat thing. Oh you're gonna love this.
You know who I've been to loop.
I've, I've been on a loop,
a tear watching Robert Klein videos cause
I, we are having him coming in and I,
and he's one of my idols and I'm watching
like Robert Klein from the tonight
show in 81 82 83 watch him on
74 on soul train or whatever.
He was fucking great man. Robert Klein
is a guy that most people don't mention,
like don't talks about
Robert Klein anymore.
As much as I mentioned prior and Carl
and Robert Klein is the most underrated
guy. I think to ever, Seinfeld always
gives them a bunch of prompts and was
talking like how he was that I think, um,
that was one of his guys. He liked
Cosby in Robert Klein I believe. And um,
I forget how he put it, but
he was like sort of their age,
like when he was doing those things in
the 70s and he was going to colleges,
like he was like that age part of that
generation. So he was kind of there.
So thank keep like Carlin was more of
a sixties guy even though he blew up in
the 70s. I think, um, people from that
generation remember him. But it's,
it's weird how some people,
despite their contributions will kind
of slipped through the cracks like that.
Uh, it's, I find with most
people that went that are like,
that they're not into self promotion.
So if you're not spoonfeeding it,
like the amount of fucking journalists
out there, if you just tell them,
you know, like, uh, I'm one of the
edgiest guys on the set. Like, what,
what not that's too, too straight.
But if you're like the, um, uh,
I would always like,
I don't know, I would,
I would equate it to Detroit
that calls itself hockey town.
Like they gave themselves a fucking
nickname. Like, why are you hockey town?
Wouldn't at least be
Montreal. Montreal Canadians.
They have the most fucking
uh, you know, championships.
They got the f the fans were literally
drive people out of town. I mean,
why? Because you're that, well no
one Michael Jackson the king of Pop,
not saying he wasn't good, but he
kind of gave himself that like,
right that nickname.
But like how a lot of hacks do that and
nobody thinks that somebody will be a
big enough asshole to give
themselves a nickname.
So people just kind of go with it.
Like people must have
called him the king of Pop,
cause nobody can be that fucking
narcissistic to give himself the nickname,
the king of pop, like probably did.
And the press loves them because
they write the story for them.
That's why they'll love a Rex Ryan.
But hate bill Belichick like
Belicheck is smart enough to be like,
you Consta going to take any little
thing that I say and turn it into Bolton
board material. That's why he stands
out gun, you know, they're good.
And I think next week it's gonna be a
tough game in just taking a long wait time
and then they want a guy
like rex Ryan go look, go,
I'm going to win the super
bowl. Then they love him.
I didn't come here to kiss the
rings. I'm going to go in there,
we're going to shove it right up
their ass. And they're just like,
before he's done talking, their article
is written. Me Wanting to go four and 12
I love Rex Ryan. I love
what a pervert he is.
I love that he loves his wife's feet.
He's the best. But he loves his wife too.
Yeah, he does. His wife keeps
him on the rails. I swear to God,
if he didn't have that guy
would ate himself to death.
I see it like all that
shit talk and he does.
You see like that's why I love that guy.
When I watch him like
he's his flaws. I'm like,
Oh my God, this guy, he's a shit
show. This guy's a shit show.
And he loves his wife to
death because she saved them.
You totally see the whole thing. Yeah.
He's a disaster. He's a disaster.
I'll try to say that a
nice. Yeah, but he is,
but there was something endearing
about that and I, you know,
I just started watching football
again. I can't care about it. I'm like,
why you are, you're the
biggest one. We were coming up.
You were a huge Campbell cowboys fan
and then you were huge Yankee Fan. Yeah.
I just, I stopped. I started
going on the road more and more.
I just stopped caring as much. I'm like,
I'm putting in so much effort to these
guys and I meet them and they don't give
a shit that I'm alive.
I had a couple of bad experiences with
athletes and I remember done. Yeah,
I was wrong about the
Jeter thing. I was a baby.
I really act like a little douchebag.
I was fucking rat. He was addicted,
not time, but I way overreacted on the
air. I'm embarrassed by that. Well,
if you, if you, if you go to the
psychology of the way you overreacted,
it wasn't really just your love for
the guys and the team. Yes, you are.
Jilted lovers. Patrice used to
always say, yeah, good lover.
That's exactly what it is. I
mean, you know, uh, the, the,
the husband that becomes a stalker is
the guy that was obsessed with his wife.
Like, you know, that's what I was,
I was obsessed with them and
then they didn't love me.
One of my biggest meltdowns was gene
Simmons cause he hurt my feelings.
He blew me off and I wanted a photo and
he was kind of a dick about it. And I,
it just ruined me and I fucking
killed him on the radio about it.
And then I kind of felt bad cause he
was nice to me. The next time I saw him,
I met him one time. He was teasing
me about losing my hair and shit.
I just so wanted to be like, dude,
do you think anybody's buying that fucking
Darth Vader helmet on you wearing a
walk in your fucking
head? That's terrible.
He has Chewbacca is heroin
dude in it is like shoe Polish,
black. I mean you, you can't,
you talk to the guy and your
kid's kid not even look at,
but what I love about him is he would
sit here and laugh right along with you
and not give a fuck and then just
scribbled down Chewbacca with hair.
And the next day there'd be a picture of
him dressed as Chewbacca with his shit
written on it and he would make $1 million
on unreal unapologetically go make $1
million off of that. He really
doesn't care. You don't.
One thing I like about Gina,
and this is one thing that Dan rather
interviewed him and he talked about,
is he's a patriotic guy.
Like nobody loves America more than
Gene Simmons because his mother was in a
concentration camp and she came here and
when he was a kid and he remembered it,
I think he was Iranian, the
biggest kiss fan. Yeah. No,
you'll way off though. That's just
about as far off. Yeah, he was.
He's a Brazilian. I thought he
was Irish. Yeah, he's a, he's a,
he was born in his name. His
real name is hime white I think.
And he was born in Israel and he said
his mother zig high old when she came to
Ellis Island.
And he tells that story to Dan Rather
about how moving it was to have them tell
her to put her armed.
So you watch that and it's like that's
the gene he should be showing people.
Why did she do that? Cause she
was, she didn't know any better.
She came to America and she had to
pledge allegiance to America to get in.
That's what you did. So she's high
and the guy put his, put her arm down.
It's like, no, no, you
don't have to do that.
So if that made gene incredible patriot,
those people were so lucky back then
that there was no youtube that would have
ruined her life. Never run for office.
Never even opened up bakery. Yeah.
The seek high. A little girl is now
coming of age to make some pastries.
Fuck you. You Hitler, love and pitcher.
Would all of that picture her with
the statue behind her? Hell yeah.
You're right. There's no live in a town
now. Do you have any clips about you?
I this, there's so many things on me
that I, that could ruin my life, that I,
I think that it's almost, there's so
many that they can't at this point.
Things I've said or you
know, things I've admitted.
Is there things in your
life that you're like, fuck,
I wish I didn't talk about
that way back. Weddings.
I didn't realize that it comes up
on me or do you not care? Yeah.
I mean I just, I mean, it's gonna happen.
It's inevitably going to happen to
everybody. They're going to go like, oh,
you said this in 2006 you'd be
like, Oh, did I? Yeah. All right,
well why don't you get your time
machine and have me apologize.
The 2006 version of me. You
know what a lot of it is,
I would equate it to the Eddie Murphy
thing where Eddie Murphy put out delirious
and he did all that,
that material about gay people and
everybody laughed and nobody said Shit.
I'm sure gay people didn't,
but mainstream did not.
And then when mainstream catches
up and starts to learn that, oh,
that's really hurtful and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah to gape,
then all of a sudden everyone's just
like, you know, they talk, oh my God,
they look the other way. Bob.
You know when they talk about that part
of the special they act. It's like,
well where were you during that year?
I know you saw it and you sat there and
left it at the same way I did. I didn't,
I didn't know that. I didn't know
what the Sh that it was to that level.
So I think you can do
that with anybody. Well,
I think what lets Eddie off the hook,
especially with that type of
material is the whole, you know,
I was giving her a ride,
excuse me for that special young lady and
boy if that didn't make me love Eddie,
nothing. Well but like after that
you're like, Eh, all right, we get it,
we get it. Who knows he could for him.
Who knows? I get involved in people's
personal lives. I don't give up. I don't
either. And not in a judgemental way.
I love the fact when when things about
let's say any celebrity come out,
they could or could not be true.
It makes me like the more like,
it makes me understand like, yeah,
this, this is a public persona.
Like I feel bad for,
there's one major actor in particular
who miss male massage therapists said he
was doing stuff and I feel so bad
for this guy. I'm like, he said,
what a torture it is to live your life.
Being afraid you're going to get caught
or being for being who you are. Yes.
Yeah. Oh God.
That's gotta be going to affect how much
money you make because of the, yeah,
that's all. It's all the, you know, some,
a lot of that personal life shit that
kind of drove me away from ESPN cause it
used to just be the games and they'd
show highlights and just seemed like a
bunch of people, you know,
broadcasting, it just loves sports.
But when they started to just keep like
delving into these people's lives and
trying to like, uh, do like the
controversy shit, I just, um, I dunno.
I just Kinda, I got away
from it after awhile.
That's why I love the sports packages.
I just taped the games
that I want to watch.
I S I blow through the pregame and I,
and I never watch any
postgame analysis or anything.
I just watched the fucking game.
That's it. And that's it. You know,
the Knicks recently handled
Hannibal burgers retreated
this thing where they did
the first half with a,
you went to the game and there wasn't a
bunch of people run around shooting tee
shirts at you every time
it was a stop at you play.
Not a bunch of music playing and all I
would would've loved to have gone to that
game. Yeah, it is distracting.
And they think we need constant
stimulation and constant noise. Like no,
we're at the game. I'm okay
just watching the game.
I'm okay if it's the third thing and it's
a, you know, two in one and this one,
I don't need care. Got Bad,
bad, bad fucking manic.
Stop it. Basketball's the worst.
Basketball is the worst just because they
run out into the court and it could be
like a really critical part of the game.
One Oh three one oh three timeout there.
There's like time for like one more shot.
These fucking assholes guy comes out in
a gorilla suit shooting tee shirts at
you and shit and it's just Kinda,
it becomes like a chuck e cheese.
You're supposed to be teaching
your kid the game here.
Like this is really important and there's
all these people that extra excited
look on their faces, they're
holding the tee shirt off. I always,
I sit through all of that, hoping
that I'm going to, you know,
nobody ever sits with me, but I have this,
this is my little fucking dream is that
I'll sit and everyone else would just
stare at fucking daggers at
them and they won't do anymore.
I don't give a fuck about a bunch of
cops smiling, jumping off a trampolines,
dunking the ball. It's actually
embarrassing. The white people like,
look how little we can jump.
It's humility. We need this here.
I saw that at a Sun's game. I had a great
time at the game, but that bullshit.
They're like, yeah, that calm that
crazy trampoline fucking guys.
And it's like fucking nine white guys
coming out there. We don't need him.
[inaudible] yeah, and there's
nobody blocking them either.
And there's mats fall. It's like a nerf
hoop, like taken to the next level.
I'm sure someone's going to tweet me. Oh,
actually that's really hard combining
those sports. But um, I hate mascots.
I think they're unnecessary
and they're stupid and they, they, they,
they child up the game. Like the I,
we interviewed the Philly fanatic in
2001 it was, I like to Philly fanatic.
Oh he smells. Those uniforms stink. I too,
I remember about being next to
the Philly fanatic, the stench.
I'm sure they all smell like that
but they [inaudible] August man.
You know you're out there
wearing some for fucking outfit.
It's horrendous and to me they just, they
do nothing to make me enjoy the game.
That's what I kind of always liked about
like I hated the mets cause fucking Mr
met and that big stupid, I love our
lack of imagination of that one.
It's just a guy with a baseball
for a head. Yeah Mister.
And then they named them after
the team. I literally is stupid.
Really comes off as the first
idea. What are you going to,
how about Mr met good
guys got a baseball head.
He's a guy.
Call him mister. We played
during Valentine's Day.
Maybe we could have Mrs. Mat.
I actually love a mascot standing on a
street corner holding up a tax tax thing
and doing a stupid dance when
I'm sitting at a red light.
It makes me laugh my fucking ass
off. I don't know what it is.
I think they should have them just,
mascots should be like in traffic,
like every 200 yards to just somebody
doing a stupid dance just to entertain
you. That's what I need. Entertainment,
not when I'm fucking attic
at an entertainment thing.
I don't need entertainment
during the interview.
In between the moments of entertainment,
you don't need the extra entertainment
and it's not even entertaining. Mascot.
You're not entertaining. I never
watched a mascot and like, oh,
that was kind of funny or cute. It's
insulting and it's really, it's,
I would say the f, the Philly
freak, the San Diego chicken.
There's a couple of classic ones
where they were actually funny. Um,
that's about it. I always
feel bad for the, uh,
couldn't they slide when they
run in and take the big slide?
Like the little guy couldn't deal it? No.
I like when like the Philly freak will
walk up and fuck with the umpires and
mess with people on the other other
team and stuff like that. It's, it's,
I don't know, like that's one of
the classic ones, but I forget, uh,
the red sox they tried to have on a long
time ago was called the Fenway freak
and he lasted like seven games. People
were just pelting him with shit,
know what was like the 70s.
This is when you could actually go
there and be a fucking alcoholic,
scare children. And then they brought
this guy out in a fucking, you know,
muppet outfit and he just got the
Philly freak, but now they have a,
Ugh, this is, is this the green monster
one? Yeah. And it's called Wally Wally.
Oh, it's like a pun. It's
a mascot with a pun, name,
Pun for what the park is known
for. Yeah. And then, then, yeah.
And then they sewing sweet Caroline
during the seven thing stretch.
Just when I thought your why YMCA Horse
Shit at the Yankees game. It's bad.
But at least the, you know, was the
grounds crew. They kind of looked like,
all right,
like they took this boring thing and
made it entertaining a little bit.
Like that was kind of interesting, um,
to watch people still spell out why
YMCA was just, yeah, that, that's,
that was always tough to watch.
I don't need to watch the ground's crew
singing what was probably the gay anthem
for 19, for the 70s.
I don't to see them fucking seen
that every seventh wedding. Yeah.
That might've been the, uh, like,
like they was so gay than the shit that
they were doing I think would actually
be offensive to gay people.
I'm a construction worker and I
have the big mustache and I'm,
the leather guy would be like, dude,
like literally now gay groups
would be like, you know,
you're perpetuating stereotypes.
We go to workings gray suits
just like you do or whatever.
But it's fucking hilarious. Do you
remember Victor Willis the lead say,
did you know what they were? I didn't
know they were gay. It was a big village.
My father took me to see
them when I was a kid.
It was them and sister sledge was the
opening band and I didn't know what
legendary, you know, disco
show. Absolutely. That was
like for that might've,
it was either them or kiss was the first
one and I didn't know they were gay,
but I found out like I didn't
know what the village was,
a grinding village thing. I had no idea
what any of that meant. I didn't either.
I thought it was cool to way, oh,
that's the construction worker guy.
Why is he construction worker? Yeah,
I didn't know that. Musicians, yeah.
Why is he just a bass player or the
Indian Phillippi rose. He's still,
he's still my favorite. I thought he
was awesome. I love this head dress.
I really did. I actually liked
the one who looked like a,
somebody who hit on Al
Pachino and cruising. Oh,
Glenn Glenn was the one I
liked. I thought he was bad ass.
Like that's why I never saw rob
Helford from a million miles away.
Cause I'm part of that last generation
where if you bought a bunch of leather
and had a mustache, you would
like some bad motorcycle.
I didn't understand that. There was a
whole other side to that. I had no idea.
But now you look back
on old Helford video,
I'll go back on Youtube and watch
old Judas priest from like a,
from that doe always that content.
They didn't like 83 and Philly.
There was that dude that just
live eight or whatever it was.
You watched priests from that and
you're like, oh, how did we not know?
That's sounds so obvious.
And I loved the fact that he
came out and nobody gives a fuck.
It's just how offered, you know, he's
like a big power top, you know, he just,
he's a, he's a fucking ramrod. I, I've
just loved the guy. Nobody gives a shit.
I think he grew into that role.
He looked like a bottom early on.
I think as he got older, you know,
we get a little more
comfortable with himself.
There's a story that he has a big Dick
and he put some guy in the hospital,
Florence, he told me his story.
If you put a guy in line,
he didn't put any person in the hospital
with your Dick. You're a legend.
And I heard that there was some,
some hairdresser who for years,
one and half for to find it. It's
consensual. Let's put that out there.
That clip gets you until they're over
18 I mean, I'm talking, you know,
the asterisk is that it's an adult and
a consensual relationship or consensual
encounter and you willingly allow him to
put your Dick and you'll end up in the
hospital. That guy's a legend. Oh,
just picture the interview afterwards
with the fucking other person.
At what moment did you realize you were
in over your head? When I was, when I,
when I told him he has to pull it out
and I realized there was still four more
interesting. Yeah.
There was some moment where he
realized this was a bad decision,
but I heard he was bugging Alford to
fuck them and he was a hairdresser or
whatever he was. Was whoever
the guy is that how for oh fuck.
Intend to the hospital and
Hallvard finally did it and
the guy wound up how you
hate fucked him. All right, fine. I'll
give you the rock star Dick. Yeah,
I hear he's packing like an animal, so
there's nothing but good, good things.
You think he did a right before his show.
So he's wearing all that
fucking awful studded shit.
It's just the sound of your screaming
in his fucking milky thighs rubbing
together the leather pants. I'm sorry
everybody. Sorry. Just paint that visual.
He smells good too. I interviewed
him before a show one time.
Me and this guy Troy from
the show went to the,
I guess it was a garden or wherever
they were where the metal a,
he smells so fucking good.
So I bought the same Cologne.
A lot of times I'll smell Cologne that
British rock stars have on and I'll buy
it and it's very specific.
It never could they make gay British
Rock Stars or just British rock star? No.
Ozzy's not gay. Ozzie's Ozzie's
the best smelling guy in music.
Ozzy smells better than anybody.
A Rob Halford smells great.
I would've never guessed that with Aussie
asking. Not Saying I, you know, just,
you wouldn't think that he smelled you
and that you wouldn't associate him with
like a really rich guy smell. But Ozzy,
you can smell from down the hall and he
has it, I think in his hair or whatever.
It's this British Cologne and he fucking,
he smells fucking amazing.
He smells amazing.
How also smelled good, but
it never smells good on me.
I buy it and I just smell like
garbage. How do you know I can,
I smell it on myself. I'm like, it stinks.
I thought you can't really smell
yourself. Oh yeah, the Cologne. You can.
I put it on and it's great for a minute
and I put my like shirt. I'm like, look,
suck. It isn't. Yeah, but that's
self hatred. No, but I don't,
I never get compliments on it. No one's
ever said, hey, you smell great in that.
Like, you know when Ozzy walks
in, people like you fucking smell.
That's the first thing I noticed about,
first time I met him was with Jim
Florentine in 97 and the first thing that
struck me is this guy smells amazing.
They're not getting enough ass.
You know what I mean? They've
got to show like Jesus Christ.
That's what you gotta fucking send
your wife into. The next room. Yeah,
go get some of you hoes.
That shit off of you police so I can
still be married at the end of this.
How funny is it that he just, you know,
he had the whole thing with shower.
We got caught having the affair and he's
not, I love that the damage control.
Ozzy does it in an interview.
He's like, well, I'm a fucking,
I'm in a fucking band on. I like, that's
his reasoning. Like what do you expect?
I thought that was the greatest.
That's something you say
to your friends though.
You don't say that in an interview.
If you play. I fucking said that.
I am too for I. If it doesn't get them
divorced, I'm happy. He said, look,
I fucking,
you might've fucking people that aren't
in his position that can easily sit
back. You know your fucking life
is. If you're not in a band,
you don't have all these women fucking
throwing themselves at you. You're like,
what the fuck is he supposed to
do? I know. I know how to use you.
You're like a grounded guy. Like I
really mean that. Like, I look at you,
you're married, you have a baby
and like you're I fucking Bose gym.
That's what [inaudible] in the green
room until everybody leaves and I booze.
They really, yeah, I admire, I sit there
and I just tell stories with people.
They bring a bottle in and I'm
with like four or five of them.
I did it the last night. I was
just in a, where the fuck was,
I stand up live in Phoenix
and they brought it,
they had this bottle for us and
for three days we just, you know,
taking a third, a third and a third
and by the last night, you know,
we just sitting in there, I go to cigar
bars. I just basically go. But dude,
I always used to look like
fucking Ralph mouth too.
So it was never really a
problem. You know what I mean?
That wasn't like a fucking
like Geraldo rest his soul.
I mean that guy was like a fucking
great in those, those guys,
you feel funny and he had a, he had
like a, I also always had like a really,
you know, angry fucking energy. So,
like most women who had even remotely had
a decent father or maybe an uncle that
they spoke to had a nice conversation
once would be running for the hills.
And I would get these absolute fucking
lunatics that would come up to me.
And um, you know, so it kind of took
care of itself to be honest with you.
It is scary when you meet women and
like the girls you dated at first or for
awhile when you realize I
represent something to her.
Like I'm an average looking guy and this,
some girls I've dated who are better,
a lot better looking than I deserved.
And like I knew that there are
mental things and I'm like,
I f I represent something weird to her.
It's a father issue. Mouthful of shame.
I would say that, you know,
yeah. It's monster rain.
I mean the names of your
[inaudible] it's very, uh, yeah,
you've carved out quite a niche
for you. So, yeah. You know,
I gotta think I gotta be honest, cause I,
what type of girl tried to blackmail me,
I needed to go and try to blackmail me
one time. She had no idea who I was.
And we had hooked up a few times,
you know, it was a money thing,
not a big expense. We had
texts, a lot of dirty fantasies,
and then she wanted me to send her money
to try and blackmail me. And I'm like,
well, I'll send you money to help you
with this, but I'm not doing it that.
And she goes, well,
maybe all your friends would want to see
your fantasies played out on Facebook.
And I'm like, you really don't
know who you're talking to. And I,
I texted it to you.
I don't give a fuck everybody who I
know knows what I'm liking what I do.
I'm at that moment. I was grateful to
be me. Yeah, you gotta be kidding you.
You know what you, when you put it all
out there and you know they can't get,
there's nothing funny.
I, one of the funny,
I watched it was a scene in a movie
watching somebody's thinking that they can
blackmail somebody and they just
completely don't give a shit do that.
Am I gonna say the guy's name? But
that happened to a hockey player.
He was like in his forties and he, I'm
all, yes. Yeah. He hooked up with some,
like 19 years old and it was legal
and everything. And she's just like,
I'm going to tweet this out and you
know, if you don't, blah, blah, blah.
He goes, what did I slept with a
smoking hot chick. Half my age. He goes,
get into it. I don't give a fuck.
And she did. Sometimes they will.
They will at times do it. She said
she was gonna he said he didn't care.
She did. And he didn't give a fuck
and nobody else did. Oh my God,
this guy did something illegal. Yeah.
She really didn't have like
a leg yesterday. I, he,
he did what we'd all love to do.
Shame on him. Good for him. But,
but if you're married,
if you got kid, you know,
there's so many guys that they like I
heard a lot of rappers get like girls will
, you know, uh, special ladies,
a lot of rappers, you know,
are a little on the DL as they
say about certain things and uh,
they get blackmailed a
lot. Like I've heard a lot.
A lot of times the girls would go, yeah,
I want $30,000 I'm going to start
fucking screaming in the lobby.
And there's been times where that
stuff has worked. It's a shame Jesus.
You can't just go, go ahead, go
screaming the lobby's stupid.
Well you know what, if everyone was like
me, you could and you like I wouldn't,
I wouldn't give a shit. I
like that's what kills me.
Like whenever a controversy
like that comes out,
like I like he were talking about that
guy with the massage therapist and all
that stuff.
I always just think like I cannot fucking
wait to go to his next movie just to
make this type of shit go away.
Cause right to support it. Yeah.
Cause even the worst case scenario is
they did something where they just fucked
up. They fucked up. What am I saying?
The guy goes on the road, he bangs,
you know, fucks around in his wife
every that's between them. Yeah.
Does that mean I don't
like that song any better?
I those fucking people who do
that shit where they just go like,
Oh fuck that guy. I'm done with this
movie. Really get done with those movies.
I'm done with his movies when his
movies suck, you know, if he's not,
if he's not out there,
you know, they'll say,
fucking people will still go to mass
every Sunday. The Catholic Church.
But you know, it wasn't
everybody. It's like,
is that really what you're thinking?
That's just your fear of dying and not
knowing where you go when you die and you
don't want to piss off the
invisible guy. All right, my buddy,
my brother said it the best.
He goes talking about the
Catholic Church. He goes,
dude, if that was any other fucking
business, they would be shut down.
Fucking shut down. I'm still on.
And I think of this a lot by the fact
that you don't believe in name calling.
I've thought of that a lot, like
how negative it is and bad it is.
And it's something that,
not that I've had a cause to
cause I'm single at this point,
but you're in a relationship with a woman.
I've never done the Europe fucking bitch
and blind w I would never of thought
and, but hearing you say
that, it's like, yeah,
I guess it really is a damaging thing to
do it I can't kick cause it builds up.
Ah, it builds up resentment
cause people don't forget like a,
I got this weird thing if my wife goes,
you know, you're a fucking asshole.
I don't care. I know other guys
that would be like, you know,
you like that would actually, it would
hurt him in a way that they as a man,
they wouldn't want to admit I don't
give a shit. Um, but like I, I,
I saw enough guys growing up doing that
you fucking bitch thing and everything
like that. And I, I just,
I saw what that did. Uh,
I was a little kid and just saw it. I
just saw it. It just, it didn't look,
you know, this big, deep voice
yelling at, you know what I mean?
It just was not, it just, I,
I dunno. So I just made a vow.
It's just one of those things. I was
like, you know what, I'm not doing that.
But then there was other stupid behavior
that I guess I didn't recognize them
then. I repeated that, but that
was the one that I, I didn't do.
So what do you do? She calls
you an asshole. You just,
he's talking about what she's
doing as if I go, oh, real mature.
I wish I had the presence
of mine ice. I, uh,
what do I do? You know, I definitely
say the f word a lot, but I don't, um,
you know what? Now that I have a
daughter, so I really, I just shouldn't,
I don't do that. I'm not gonna fucking
sit there and screaming. You can't. Yeah.
When there's a baby in the road,
it's really changed that we can Sam my
radio part and just had a baby and see
everybody I know is having kids. He, I
guess it changes the way you do shit,
right? Yeah. Because the,
there's that whole, uh,
I think for the first time in your life,
you're actually aware of your
behavior affecting other people with,
you know, with your girlfriend or your
wife. It's an adult to adult thing.
So you really don't,
you're like, oh, this,
especially as an adult that can drive
a car, you know, I can say this stuff,
this isn't going to affect them, you know?
But it's when you have the kid and
everything and it's just like, you know,
that this could actually affect
who they marry, right? Oh yeah.
This, that literally, you know,
if I do what I'm, you know,
if I flip out right now
and I consistently do this,
this could literally drive my daughter
to a trailer park someday. Right.
You know, and, and be one thing,
if I was just completely oblivious that
I could just sit at a bar, Go, Nah,
she's a fucking lojack yet out. She grew
up in a house. Now she said a thing,
but I am kind of aware of the effect
of it now and then I would have to sit
there and take on that kind of guilt.
So, um, plus I, I don't know. I, I don't,
um, I just growing up, that was a
lot of just the era when I grew up,
like every authority, authority
person was just so not approachable.
And as I said this, and this is what
it is, and you shut the fuck up.
And it was that just, you know, that's
kind of what stoked the whole fire in me,
I think. So I try to, uh, you know,
I think you go one of two ways.
You either repeated or you just
remember that. So like, um,
I actually got a really good compliment
from somebody one time. It's like,
you know what? He goes, Mike, you
should gotta come by, come by my house.
He goes, my kids love you. And I was
like, really? He goes, yeah. He goes,
they let you talk to
them like they're adults.
I wasn't even aware I was doing it like
I would be talking to like is a 10 year
old you? What grade are you in a you
getting homework now? Oh that sucked.
I hated that.
Like I wasn't thinking that I was and
they kind of liked it that they were
talking to adult like, oh this is,
this is somebody older who they think
knows everything he's saying how he hated
it. Kinda gave him make an admitted
okay. To be like, oh this sucks man.
I hope that did make them not do their
fucking homework, but I would just,
you know, I would address it rather than
being like, no, you need to sit down.
You need to learn that this is what
life is. It's sitting there doing shit.
You don't want to do like that so much
that you learn that, that you like,
you don't think that you can
actually go out and achieve shit.
Like life becomes like, fuck, when
is this over? Just staring at it
at a clock and people saying that,
I think you have the times don't even
mean it. They just think it should.
An adult is supposed to stay like
to say like, you know what I mean?
You should know you buckled down.
You tell you what if I said that
anybody out internally beyond shut up.
You don't fucking believe that I cannot
wait to tell my daughter. I don't know.
I cannot wait to tell it. Why is this
blah blah blah. And I'll just, I dunno.
I don't know why I be like, well
you know, cause I don't read. Why?
I don't know cause it makes me sleepy.
I'm just gonna fuck brutal honesty.
I'm just gonna own up to
it. There's a lot of stuff.
Your dad isn't good at sweetheart.
You want some ice cream? Yeah.
Cause you want, I, I'm, I'm in
the middle. Like I, you know,
I'm at a point where I'm 48 no wife,
no girlfriend. Like I, you know,
I don't know if I'm, if I'm
the best boyfriend candidate,
but I'm tired of being single. Like
I'm, I'm kind of, oh, there you go.
That's where I take of it.
You got sick of it, right?
Yeah, I got a no, you know
what he did was I finally,
I just looked at like what I was doing
and then you know, we have to like,
I used to joke about that on stage Jeff,
like the 90th fucking person that
doesn't go well and there's only so long
you've been doing these chicks are fucking
psychos and after a while it's like,
what am I doing?
I chased him away in tech.
I've had some updated dated
literally for I lose in text message.
Oh I'm so, I'm so like I want
to either talk dirty or I just,
I just want to keep pushing the envelope
and the next thing you know I'm,
they stopped talking to me so I
know I'm doing something wrong.
It's not them then and I'll talk it over.
I'm just creeping them out on
some level. I don't know why.
That just reminded me this
last night, I was watching a,
what does that fucking show with Andy
Cohen where he does the wrap ups of the,
uh, the real housewives. Oh, Ron, not
his talk show is look what happens live.
Yes. That shot. Oh, that one. So
my wife always watches that show.
That's one of those crossover
shows. I have to watch what they're,
so we don't battle over
the T. Right, right.
So I'm watching it with Jennifer
Lopez and I'm, oh Jesus Christ.
It just went blank on
his, uh, Ray Liotta dude.
Ray Liotta was fucking hilarious. He
just answers, he doesn't give a shit.
You know, he doesn't, he just answered
everything straight up. Straight up.
They were like, what? So for
cocaine, like in Goodfellas,
like what are they using? It was
like cocaine just to say that.
And they would be like, who's the
most, he, they play this thing.
You can plead the fifth. And He, oh yeah,
he never, p never pleaded the fifth.
Would they ask him? They
asked him like, uh, Oh,
who's the worst kisser of, of anybody?
He said, you've been with this person,
but that's what was first. And you
know, Andy's doing all the things.
So who was the worst kisser? Like this
was going to be the thing. He goes, uh,
well, I don't think I kissed
any of them. And he goes,
well then who would you
guess? And he goes, oh,
Sigourney weaver just set him bigger.
Who's the worst act or most overrated
actor or the 90s? And he goes,
most overrated. He goes back and
I'd probably say Clint Eastwood,
and then somebody mumbled,
blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah was surely [inaudible] want. He
goes, I don't give a shit. Just like
he is kind of untouchable at this point.
He is rally Yoda. He gets, you know,
he know. But it was real. It wasn't
a cop trying to be dangerous.
He literally goes, I don't give
a shit. I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit. I'm fucking, I'm
Ray Liotta. And by the way, I who I am,
I don't give a shit what
a brilliant game that is,
plead the fifth on one of these
three questions. Then what it'll do,
it was then it would then pass it over
to you and then you gotta you know,
and it's all this, this, uh, you know,
he did all these squirming questions
like he was asking like Jennifer Lopez.
Okay. When you, you know, I mean, you've
been proposed to five times, did you?
Who did you say no to? And she's
nice person doesn't want to say it.
And Ray Liotta was just sitting
there going, just plead the fifth on.
I'll answer something like he just
completely didn't give a shit. Oh,
who is the two of them together? Yeah.
Cause they're on that cop show together.
Oh, you know, it's fun. I audition
for that. Uh, I did. Yeah, I did.
Doug Davidoff got the
part and he lazy. He,
I think he's better for that than I
am anyway. Not just acting ability,
but you know, he looked
more of the part of a,
a kind of a slick like internal
affairs guy if that's who he was.
I didn't know Doug was on that shit.
Yeah. Yeah. He's got a good part.
He brought railroad into the comedy
cellar one night. Um, but you know,
if I'm not going to get it, I'd
rather see somebody I like yet.
That's great. Now he brings in a glimpse
of what your life would have been.
Yeah. Cool. Hanging with Bailey
odor, that would've been fun.
That would've been kind of
Nice. Jim, you're on next.
What should I say about you? Yeah, it'd
be the, you know, she'd gone up. Sorry.
That was my bad STM. Pros like she
announces you before you go on,
but I understood what you're saying. Oh,
like is bad is that joke was everybody,
uh, Chuck Norden special is going to be
the opposite of that mouthful of shame.
I, I, it's so stupid to
keep going back to this.
When people listen to a podcast, it's
not like that because there's no, right,
there's no commercials coming in for it,
but I just feel like I have
to keep going back to it.
March 14th in case you forget,
because then they got to rewind and
try to remember where and way of course
we'll probably tweet it
out. I did love Netflix too.
I've never done anything with them before.
I know you've done a bunch of stuff
with them, but they're so easy.
They're like, all right,
just put it together. I need,
Robbie had a couple of minor suggestions.
They don't overly manage you.
It was like fucking great.
It was so nice to do it and I'm
actually happy with it. Like,
you know you shooting at me like
this one. I actually feel it's,
it's dirtier than I kind of intended.
And wait till next time you go to
Australia, now that it's on, on Netflix,
like you'll sell tickets. You
go home. I'm going to a you.
I told you you inspire
me completely to to do,
I'm only doing this stuff because you
got in my head and I hear bill burn my
fucking head all the time. God Damn.
What are you waiting for? And I'm like,
I gotta do it. I really do. It's
like, but you are right now.
Watch y'all stop selling
tickets. And I'll be like,
you watching Davidoff coming in with ray.
I'll be watching you selling out the
fucking, what does that thing and Sydney,
the Opera House. I'll be like. I used
to do that. I, I, you know it's funny,
I did one show there. It
was a TV tape. No it was,
it was a TV taping and something else.
And I enjoyed Sydney. Melbourne was good,
but Sydney was really good and I'm like,
like Melbourne a little bit better.
You did? Yeah,
I got then park was fun cause I landed
there and was Australia day and everybody
was just fucking getting hammered
and shit. So I was like, hey this,
this country. I didn't go to Perth.
I didn't go was your first time through
was great. And Perth as the Bond Scott.
Oh, buried there. They got the stash.
Yeah, we did it. We went to the bond.
Scott Wall and Melbourne.
It was like in one of the things someone
painted attribute all the bond. Scott,
you know it's Bon Scott because they says
ACDC. But if it didn't, you'd be like,
you know, or say they say acadeca
down there. I don't know why. Oh,
do they really? Yeah. And then what is,
what is Burger King call down there?
I don't remember a
fucking cheese. Yeah. No,
it's something enough friends. No,
cause somebody down there actually had
already had a burger king and he sued the
corporation and they, what the fuck
is it? You're looking it up, Jonathan.
Um, did you still take us when you
first went through the first time? No.
You know,
I think I did the first time I went out
there it was like an oh four and I did
something for a comedy central and
we flew in from, from New York,
so it was like six hours to five and a
half to la and then lay over and then 14
hours and you land, they let you
sleep a little bit and then it's like,
it's already the next day.
And then we taped it and then the next
day he's supposed to go back with so
fucking nuts. And so I was
just like, well fuck that.
I'm going to stay here for a few days.
Hungry Jacks, Hungry Jacks. That's right.
Hungry Jacks. That means nothing
to anybody listening to this.
But I thought it was cool. Um,
and I just hung out there and I bought
all these ACDC albums on CD that the,
the original like, like was t and
t h to know the names of these,
like t and t was the original album
that then became high voltage,
but their version had
like dirty deeds on it,
which later became [inaudible] album and
an EAP over here. So we went, you know,
I bought like a, all these, you know,
cause I got a big family so I just bought
them for all my brothers and sisters.
Yeah. And uh, drove around,
saw the apostles and just driving on
the other side of the road was really
fucked up. And anytime I went to
take a turn, like the joke was,
I would just pretend that I wanted to
kill myself and then I would actually make
the right decision. Cause everything
else, it doesn't even make sense.
You're like, what the fuck? This makes
no sense. Especially when you're, um,
when you make a right turn and
you're sitting, you're sitting on,
on the passenger's side and you gotta
go wide. You're like, what the fuck?
You just picture like a semi. But
late at night when I came out,
I didn't know where the fuck I was
at, but I was with this other comic,
one of those comics.
It was from like Scotland or some shit
and ex patriot and I just met him and I
never saw him again. But uh,
we got on the road with no streetlights
and drove probably maybe eight,
900 feet and the same time we both went
like, oh shit. Oh Shit. And got over.
But there was nobody coming. We're
definitely was starting to go up a hill.
So yeah, I'm sure people get car
service when you're out there. Jimmy.
That's what I'm trying. I, we overheard
when I was there, I mean Uber's there,
it was great, but I'm,
I'm mostly going to Norway and I think
I'm doing something Scandinavian and I've
never been to any of these
places. I'm doing all of them.
That whole run through a Oslow, Helsinki,
Stockholm Dude [inaudible] the best,
but they see those are just places that,
you know, as an American to
actually go there. I mean,
I think you gotta be like,
either you're either in the Illuminati
or you're like a downhill ski or some
shit.
Cause other than that you're not going
to go there as far as just not on our
radar to go there. Beautiful countries
and the people that the people are great.
Do you fly in and out the city? Can
I have sleep apnea and I fucking,
I take Dramamine to fly. Like I came
this morning from Portland, so I'm like,
I'm very loopy and I'm tired and you'd
just do a show that night and then fly
out the next morning. I can't, there
was a, um, I'm panicking about that.
What I do is I turn it into
like a paid vacation. So, um,
what I do is I fly over there and I
either do the tour and then I meet my wife
afterwards or other times I've done it
like just because of our schedules that
work out. Like, all right, let's do
the vacation first. Um, and then, uh,
not only will I be
rested, I'll be, you know,
talking about to acclimate it to
the time and that type of thing.
So I've done both, but, uh, you know,
there's all, you know, I build a little,
I build a lot of shit around
sporting events and stuff. Like,
you know what I wanted
to go to this year. I,
I don't think it's gonna work out
though, but I was going to go to that,
there's this motorcycle
race on the Isle of Man,
which is an island between Britain
and Ireland home saying that, right?
A fucking whales, whatever the
fuck you want to call it. Um,
and it's just this fucking motorcycle
race that's just like, I mean,
more people have died than
years. They've had it.
It's just finally they go on like fucking
200 miles an hour down these country
roads and shit and they go, go
like come blazing through town.
I mean it's like if you love the
beginning of the last mad max,
this is like the closest you're going
to see to the real version of it.
I mean it, dude, these
guys are fucking lunatics.
Like you know that going so fast and
it takes little ass country roads and
there's like stone walls and
shit and trees like yeah,
dead and pedestrians are getting
killed once in awhile too.
I'm actually surprised that so many
people stand so close that my only
nervousness about it is how can I get
high up enough to see a little bit more of
it. Right. Because I'm worried that
it's just going to be like, you know,
I'm going to stand and go fly halfway
around the world and just see he like
and then stand there for like another
fucking 20 minutes because they go buy
that fucking fan and that's it. Yeah.
I went to the Daytona 500 and we
were on the Indian field on like,
I'm like this little building so I could
actually stand and kind of watch him go
all the way around. Um,
but like if you just stand,
the first time I went to
the Indy 500, I was just,
you're just in a corner and it just
becomes this drinking game and everybody's
bet on like four different cars and you
just pray to God there's going to be an
accident or some shit in front of you.
Right. Just something interesting. Yeah.
And it's actually really amazing the first
time you see it and you actually hear
this tire skid like a real
accident. You're like, oh yeah,
I guess it is a car for some reason I
never thought it would sound like that.
But the thing is that going so fast as
they'll hit the wall in front of you and
then the debris just, they fly down
the scene. The accidents. Yeah.
I saw a guy hit a wall in front of
you one time, but it's like, it's,
he hits it in front of you and by the
time your brain reacts to what that is,
he's already a quarter mile away. It's
not like they hit it and just stop.
Do you watch like boxing and MMA cause
you such as sports care, do you watch uh,
combat sports? Yeah, I keep
going in and out of MMA.
It's like to pence up my road
schedule where it's like, you know,
I work a lot on Saturday night if a couple
months goes by and I keep missing the
fights. I hate it, but it's a
big thing that me and my wife do.
Like she fucking loves it. The
shit like UFC dude, she's old.
She's almost embarrassing. Like she
gets up and yells at the TV. Oh Great.
She totally gets into it. When, um,
Anderson silver like had the compound
fracture of his leg, I was like,
oh my God, look in away.
And she has this weird thing where
maybe she should have gotten the medical
field cause she was, it wasn't
like she was happy it happened.
She was just more fascinated by what
it looked like. It was just like,
good Lord. Oh yeah. I always
call it. That's like the uh,
when they break that fucking thing,
that's like you have a like a little kid
put on like his dad's rain boot steps
on the side and just folds up.
Like I can't, I cannot look at it.
I was at that fight. That was
their second fight. That was a,
nobody knew what happened like until the
replay you just saw him fall and then
the replay played the whole place was
like, oh it was, that was a horrible,
but he's still kicking.
He's still using that leg.
He thought I heard when you break the
bone though doesn't come back stronger.
Some weird reasons they might
have strengthened it with metal.
I heard it was a pretty clean break.
Here we go. We're going into the best.
Doesn't make it stronger. You
heard they did metal? Yeah.
We don't know but he's able to
fight with it. Let's just give
answers Jeff. We don't
see why it happened.
I remember over hearing somebody say
that and I never did any background check
on them. And have you gone to one
of the fights? Yes. Yes I did.
What is that? Oh is that the picture
of him going by on the stretcher?
Jesus Christ. Jim, you look like
you're in a fucking band dude.
I gotta tell you, this guy took
this weight off, what, two,
three years ago and you've kept it
off. What are you doing? I just,
just eating in the gym. Just
that, that really is it.
But when did you find that? Cause you,
you are you one of those
up and down there is awful.
It's just that moment of
clarity. I'm just like, ugh.
Just so much fucking self discussed.
What were you eating and
where were you when you,
when you finally were just like,
I can't do this anymore. You know,
I really don't remember. I W I do remember
is just going to the gym and going,
I am going to go. I, I was
fucking, I was just sick of like,
when you feel it in your back above your
belt, that little bit of fucking fat.
It's just soft. Like a little
lamb. I started getting the, uh,
the effort noises, putting on socks.
I was just like, Oh God, I'm becoming
that guy. So I just like, uh,
this last trip I just had, I got off the
road two days ago now I've just been,
it's so funny,
I literally just two days of not eating
burger king or steak and shake and I
never, I just kind of fell into this.
I think it was just because of the lack
of sleep I've been getting and just
going out on the road and then having
to do the shows and the pressure,
putting them together in the new hour.
I just spent under a lot of stress
that I've just been like last second,
I'll fuck, I'm hungry now. Let's
go here. I don't give a shit,
just stuff they send me and fill up
the hole. And it just was, uh, yeah.
So La is dangerous for me cause I go,
this is what a fucking fruit I'm turning
into. Jonathan and I will look at word.
It is a great fucking fruit. We
eat. Uh, I like eating Sushi here,
but then we go to the yogurt
stop on Santa Monica Ball.
I've been going there for years.
They think we're a couple.
It's my favorite place in the world.
There's The fucking yogurt stop on
Santa Monica. I love, where is that?
It's on Santa Monica by rage West.
Target. Get get, get on. Mike.
I know you're just talking
to Jonathan. Forgot. Put on,
put on the fucking headphones. You just
speak into thinner. Jonathan Brownstein.
Everybody. Oh, hello?
Yeah, Jonathan [inaudible],
who was very instrumental when we
first started doing the poetry.
So Neil benefit. That's right.
What's helped me get in touch with
all the guys and everything like that.
And uh, it's an amazing thing. It's
still going on. It's incredible. Yeah.
Just let you know how much you
have. No, no, no. It's more retard.
[inaudible] Taryn deals with
all the infrastructure and a,
the heard of add that is booking a
bunch of comedians. Dude, it's hard.
Literally, it's like you got 12
cows just fucking, oh, I guess what,
what runs cows don't run.
You've got 10 things.
You got 10 fucking things that run
there. We're going a different direction.
Things that run all going in different
directions. But if February 21st,
that normally wouldn't this,
right? Yes. So we kind of,
we kind of know it's going
to be in February now.
Now she lets us know when enough
advanced, that's why we do it Tuesday.
Cause sometimes fans go, why the
fuck is this on a Tuesday night?
It's cause cause
guys are working for free and this is
what, that's the day when comedians are,
uh, are in town. So, uh, next year, uh,
I already know like one of
the guys out here every year,
we try to like maybe
fly somebody in and uh,
we got an idea of possibly who we're
going to try to use this next year. But,
uh, it's been a great thing
cause I just hate like, you know,
like when someone passes away like
with unfortunately where at that age,
you know, and where you had that one
time benefit and you're like, okay,
here's your Sacca cash, good luck
for the next 40 years. And it's um,
you know, he was taking care
of those people. So it's,
it's definitely been a great thing.
So the, and the thing about us,
here's the B I think of this too this
year, is that it's the fifth annual one.
I have officially done this four more
times and Patrice would've done it for me.
[inaudible] this year, I
think might've been this year.
I thought it was perfect combination
of a great mix of people.
The ball breaking was on a whole
other fucking level. And then, uh,
when Leslie Jones told that Patrice
Story, oh my God, it was just fucking,
no dude. The shit that you said. When
Keith to Keith and Keith Robinson,
Keith Robinson, Keith unfortunately,
uh, suffered a mild stroke. Uh,
was it moment coming up on two years
ago? Was it? No, less than a year. Yeah,
a year and a year ago.
And um, he's, you know,
of course now he's doing like some of
the funniest shit or whatever. So Jim,
when he out-tro to meet, goes
keeping going for Keith Robertson,
he should have had a stroke 15 years
ago. The place fucking dies laughing.
And then your other one was like, uh,
what's funny is even after a stroke,
Keith is easier to understand
than rich Vons. That was,
I don't know how you followed it with
the rest of your jokes, but people like,
yeah, people like the
attacks on each other that,
that's always a crowd favorite.
You had one where you said,
I think Colin came after you and
you said, Da, he's here. He's a,
has to be back at men's warehouse soon.
Cause he was wearing a suit
that night and it was, oh God,
my boss's awful hat this year.
And Pete Davidson kept telling them the
truth going, it looks off. I'm like,
Pete, that's not how this game works.
Tell him it looks good and you wait
till he goes out on stage. Yeah.
You don't try to discourage him.
You wait until he's on and then you
fucking attack him in front of the entire
theater. It was another, another one.
That's the first time we had him
and he came out and he was trashed.
And Voss has had, I think they actually
made making fun of us as the old guys.
Um, I, I, yeah, I think that,
but then vos leveled him. Oh.
Cause Pete Pete Talks about his dad dying
on at 11 and voice said the one good
thing is that, uh, uh, he,
Pete's dad didn't have to see him in
that blouse and he said he would have
thrown himself in another fire. Oh yeah.
That fucking, oh my God,
that terrible sweater.
He had artsy golden girls sweaters.
Yeah. That was really bad. It was really,
really shitty. I wanted to make fun
of it, but I knew I didn't like it.
I'm like, you're on a TV show,
you're your fucking good looking young
guy and if you dressed slightly a
feminine, it's like you're
not getting enough put sticks.
So I knew that that's what I was
going to come out. And I was like,
I can't come at him. Like the potential
was wrong. Yeah. I knew that I was just,
uh, an old man getting jealous, you know,
now I had Derosa just showed
up and that then I, I have,
I mean the sweater off by itself should
have been burnt. It was brutal. It was,
it was bad. But you knew the reasons
for attacking it would have been more.
Yeah. It's like one of those
fucking guys. Remember those,
those all those people that Madonna used
to fucking sell home in New York City.
Those, yeah, those Jelly Bean
Beneatha's. Those artists. Yeah.
He looked like he fucking,
when he dies his artwork,
it was going to be worth something.
Yeah. Like a young, uh, I
believe I have a Basquiat. Yeah.
The young guy of AIDS. That's
what I'm thinking of. Yeah.
Kenny, those guys,
because it always makes me feel foolish
because everybody looks at this shit
like it's fucking amazing. And
like one of the, uh, I dunno,
like the two ladies when I always know
that I'm a dope was when I tried to read
out loud that and when I go to a museum,
because I mean,
do you want to just talk about
flatlining emotionally and it just,
it means not dude. I went,
when I went to Paris,
I went into a Lulu. I could not
get out of there fast enough.
I was like literally almost shouting
at people. Like, where is it?
Where is the fucking,
where's the Monalisa so I can look at
it and get the fuck out of here and you
get out of it. And there's all
these people that just, you know,
just creating like a alleged with their
other hand and then fucking holding
their chin with the other one.
And I was just, I just sort of,
I peered over like it was the presidential
motorcade drive and by on book.
That was it. Did it move you? And he
didn't give a fuck. The only thing I was,
cause it's been recreated so many times.
He'd be like, that's the actual one.
That's it. Yeah. Dude, I saw the Sistine
Chapel. I could be all fucking smaller.
Was I think that guy was dogging it.
I mean it's saying it took
them that fucking long.
Yeah. I walked in, I literally
was like, this is it.
And somebody went sh sh like shushed me.
I'll tell you what would be on inspiring
that they recently dug up Christ's tomb
and the church and they had to do
something. They know where he's buried up.
They know where the suppose the
tomb of Christ. They do know. Yeah,
it's is supposedly fucking Al Capone's
vault probably is the shroud of Turin.
It probably is bullshit, but
I mean it is in Catholicism.
They do kind of revere it somewhere
and you know Jerusalem I guess.
But these guys had to go down and they
were doing some kind of maintenance work
on it, which they had to be done on
the lid over the tomb. But I'm like,
that would probably get me like, Ooh,
this is a pretty important place.
But then the art museum
to do nothing for me.
I did see the Washington crossing the
Delaware painting. It's fucking massive.
It's probably the size of this room
right now in the Metropolitan Museum art.
That was kind of,
what was it that I would rather look at
that shit than something like abstract.
Yeah, me too.
That look like you've rolled a baby and
paint and just fuck it through it. Yeah.
Canvas. I liked
to the van goal one when where? Wherever
the fuck whatever country that's in.
I went to that and I
actually liked that one.
And it's not because he's a fellow
fucking redhead. It was just,
I actually liked within Netherlands. Yeah.
How about uh, I like a Norman Rockwell.
You sure it's not in Denmark? Copenhagen?
I thought it was Amsterdam, but maybe it
could be the whole way. You dressed me.
Let's me know. I know, I
know that you're right.
He has his initials on his shirt.
He gives like the air of authority,
but half the times he knows
what he's talking about.
Half the times he does that. Oh,
this is that what you have your initials
right there? Yeah. That's very unique.
Yeah. The Taylor's, is that
near your, uh, your pancreas?
Is that why you put it there? I
thought you did it on the cuff link.
On the cuff. There's two styles. You
can do it. The cuff. You can do it here.
You can. What is that and what
does that style? I don't know.
I've always had it here though,
so I don't know the tailor that I got
this made yet. He did it there, gentlemen.
Yeah. John does a true
gentleman. Yeah, the truth.
I can tell how difficult you are as a
client because I know when you're not
around, his shirt is untucked. Yeah.
He's got a little rock and roll.
Cause I'm in town case, there's chicks
to talk to get him to the Greek.
Um, all right, well coming up on an
hour here at Jim, I'm, I'm s, you know,
I'm such a fucking huge fan. You
and I always tell you this dude,
I owe so much of the tickets that I sell
to on the road that you were generous
when you got,
a lot of guys would've got that opie and
Anthony Gig and they would've kept the
fucking door closed and you let us all
run in. So, uh, I I want to thank you.
You know,
you can see I'm blowing all my money
on footlocker tee shirts here now.
But you do it. You do a well,
deservedly like you're a great comic.
And I mean it's like, yeah,
we're going to try to top my compliment
with the compliment you send them.
It is nice to see like mouthful
of shame on Netflix March 14th.
I love you to death, Jimmy. Uh, all
the success in the world to you.
I will definitely be tweeting this out.
If you want to talk to Jimmy Norton,
you can get him on Twitter at, at Jim
Norton, Instagram at Jim Norton Facebook.
Just type in Jim Norton and Jim
norton.com. And you got here,
me and Sam in the morning. I have
to plug most Sam Roberts. Uh,
we are now doing the show
together Monday through Friday,
eight to 11 on Channel One oh three.
I have satellite radio now and I look
at the list of new guys all the time.
It's great. It's really
finally get caught up. Oh,
I can't believe how long I did
satellite radio before I got it.
It's fucking tremendous. You
just got it. I just got it.
I never had it in my car
and I finally just said,
I finally never bought myself a nice car.
I'm one of those frugal fucking
Douche bags. So I finally just said,
I'm buying a nice car. Have an idea.
I was just like, whatever. They said,
you want this? I was like,
yes. Do you want that? Yes.
Treating yourself climate control.
Yes. I just said yes to everything.
That's why it gets shitty gas mileage is
so fucking heavy with all the options.
Thanks for have me. Sorry, I was late
too. Oh, you weren't late, Jimmy.
I appreciate you. We're building
anticipation and I'll see you guys.